of course why don't you just quit
YouTube rate you're done with Exodus
you're welcome no punishment must be
more severe true not just of your
channel
[Music]
[Music]
become those unwelcome video platform
owners credit content here over the
decades look to the larger channels and
aspired to monetize so so simple menu
create urban band trying know true
despair without hope so to terrorize
YouTube I will let them believe that
YouTube can simply be on our channel so
that they can watch all the peering mock
remembers swarm YouTube with free
content to stay on the paxil
you can watch his mock remembers to shut
into our internet and then when YouTube
and social media dance we understood the
depth of that
[Applause]
no problem fulfill its destiny destroy
label isn't cool and then what it is
done and YouTube is awesome
they're not my permission for God
[Music]
[Music]
gravy's yes I do wish that we were
meeting under less unfortunate
circumstances before we get to questions
for those asking the proper steps to be
taking at this current moment given how
little information is known we will
advise you on the proper precautionary
measures which is most important
thoughts impress the families affected
and of course naturally changing your
Twitter avatar yeah what about the
reports that Isis has take your
responsibility no they have well we
can't comment on that of course because
these topics or a sensitive nature we'd
hate for people to go off with opinions
half-cocked over we can't advise you
give me the current situation the best
measures to be taken still remains
changing your Twitter avatar yeah man
you have detained is it true he has ties
to Islamic terrorism nope let's not use
that word inflammatory language and I
will say regardless of the motive that
does not change the precautions needed
to be taken by the average citizen in
changing your Twitter avatar most
important yes yeah what about my avatar
though think about if you like it but
that's a valid question particularly for
those with a verified check mark you've
gone to great lengths and spare no
expense for their head shots and then
avatar if you like your current Twitter
avatar you can keep your avatar you can
simply add an avatar through the
application in his Photoshop overlaid
over your current avatar simultaneously
layer drop the opacity no more further
questions thank you hey yo glad to see
you here today
Gavin McGinnis on the show today yeah
firuzan with me in video studio as
always as Jared who is not gay follow
him on Twitter Mia s Crowder with your
questions comments thoughts having a
conversation today I fill filled my
legal obligations story on conclusions
are we good
we're good thank you @g Morgan Jr whoa
how you doing how you
I'm doing well listen it's been it's
been a tough day so let's just address
the giant suicide vested elephant in the
room obviously our thoughts and prayers
are with the families of those affected
with the Manchester bombing but you know
what quite a
more than that and if you missed my
video from this morning we're going to
talk about it more later on in the show
we're going to talk about the leftist
reaction everything that we know up to
this point we'll be talking about it
with Gavin so yeah thoughts and prayers
but you know what
I don't we do a little more than that
maybe atheists and and agnostics and
Christians can come together where it's
nice the lip service is cool but we'll
try and do a little bit more give you
some specifics okay well let's get some
other news first though Huffington Post
blossoms those hearts just to have this
headline socialism is so hot right now
thank Bernie Sanders now at first I
thought I was a typo I remember when
people said they thought Barack Obama
was socialist no that's just you just
you're secretly saying n-word it's
pejorative racial pejoratively well and
then they said it's not socialism it's
it's democratic folk socialism
yeah that's just pure socialism that's
right socialism is all the rage and when
asked for comment
Venezuela responded with no no no me
gusta year followed by inaudible sounds
of starving and economic collapses oh
that's tough it is it's tough it's tough
to get common pundit read more let's
have a quote more general sentiment of
country Bernie Sanders praised
breadlines yeah if you think about it
sexually it's a beautiful thing it's
good no it's not it's not you crazy old
cat man hoarder but we know someone who
lived in his old college house who moved
in after him he is in fact a hoarder I
believe it I can't substantially yeah
actually Matt Matt one of our guy who's
tempting as an editor right now he can
tell you yeah I didn't live there but he
knows someone who did I buy it all right
this was a story at a California man
died after contracting botulism from
Northern California gas stations
nacho-cheese a guy died it sucks and
several more people were sick an
investigation was conducted which ended
very abruptly when the detectives
realized the botulism originated from
gas station nacho cheese
she's been an indicator the story meets
climax conclusion all the time I'm
entitled you know speaking of which
Indonesia don't you into yours the funny
thing it's a moving target we'll talk
about this today with Islam Islam just
sucks doesn't it it just sucks big old
camel will have to censor that I am so
tired of it and I'm so tired of us
having to act as though none of it we
don't look there's this unwritten
agreement like oh you know what maybe
maybe you know no it just sucks a big
old sweaty camel ballsack the entire
religion I'm tired of it so it's not
that elevator art I'm getting it you
know it's beautiful I'm sorry to get it
I'm sorry yeah it's like it's like a
magic eye painting I think no no if you
look at if you don't look through it you
just end someone's being blown up that's
the same thing because it's a moving
target right before used to be the UAE
Lebanon was the it was what are they
used to like the Paris of the Middle
East Lebanon and then they switched it
to Malaysia and Indonesia now they're
pivoting away from that to Morocco
because Islam can't get its crap
together in any country for more than
about a decade and a half historically
give it two decades being generous so in
Indonesia here's another story from the
good old tolerant progressive Indonesia
two men were caned for homosexual sex
they were caned the punishment process
took about 45 minutes to administer it
was one minute to Cain the perpetrators
in 44 minutes to wipe the smiles on
their faces I didn't get a lot of sleep
and that's why if you didn't you watched
you in the video that came out the
reason I had the vent in that video
today with that horrible cell phone
camera footage was because I fight it we
didn't get it out we wouldn't have been
able to have fun today sir um but let's
talk about it the Manchester bombing and
Gerald obviously has taught courses and
apologetics has been on the course quite
a bit so we're glad to have you here man
up talking about Islam first up some
that stood out we know a lot now we just
you just ran that over late night right
we know the guy obviously Islamic yeah
don't jump to conclusions but yeah I
wish to put vetting odds on that yeah
they put a 60% chance of Donald Trump
being impeached
I wish after any two
attack there were Vegas betting odds
yeah I'm like is it white supremacy we
will give you a hundred and eighty-five
to fraction of one odds a plumber that
is that liberals are bankrupt themselves
and then conservators have to bail him
out of that too yeah I really I said it
wasn't like crusty but it gets the
Harlem Globetrotters so BBC reporter
Katty Kay said that Europe should get
used to this Europe is getting used to
attacks like this Mika what we have to
because we are never going to be able to
totally wipe this out as Isis gets
squeezed in Syria and Iraq we're going
to see more of these kinds of attacks
plate taking place in Europe and Europe
is starting to get used to that none of
us are used to having children targeted
in this way young girls target hidden in
this way I understand what you saying I
don't want to take her out of context
I'm more upset that I wasn't shocked
yeah let it Kurt my wife said that when
she got up I I didn't want to let her
know right away I didn't want to ruin
her day I knew about it late last night
working on the site and she was already
in bed and I brought her you know her
morning breakfast beverage I just didn't
know anyone I told her I said you know
gosh I'm just so upset that I'm I'm not
surprised and that should tell you the
low expectations that we have globally
for Islam there's nothing more honest
than looking yourself in the mirror and
saying you know what I'm really not and
I I was enraged this morning that I
wasn't surprised did anyone else feel
that way I did I kind of rolled my eyes
and said here we go again
yeah I we've talked about it like
there's been a little bit of a lull in
these massive things but there's been
some stuff obviously in Europe that
we've heard about yeah but it's like
yeah yeah no this is this is how they
work well I was raising can't oh go
ahead that's problem to a lull now is
like oh it's been a month yeah exactly
that's that's that's our definition is
everyday like catching world that's a
nice to come on the show and it seemed
like every couple of weeks that's what
I'm talking about
and just I don't understand why people
don't get it like I'm well you know I'll
tell you why because I was raised in
Canada and I talked about this in the
video that we were at least I remember
after 9/11 comedian saying well you know
you this is this just happened to the
states if you don't see it happening
anywhere else you don't see it happening
and
ana de you don't see it happening in
Europe and in Denmark they're not
attacking places in Spain it has
happened everywhere that they've
mentioned now so that was the argument
kind of like a big argument against the
Christian faith we've talked about this
was well David is one of the most
important biblical historical figures
there's no evidence of him before 1993
and then when they that was the crux of
the anti-christian argument geologically
and historically and then when they did
find evidence they move the goalposts
yeah yeah what's the same thing with
well the United States is provoked they
look they attack the u.s. more than me
well now they attack everyone else so we
move the goalposts yeah I mean let's
look at it as European appeasement
worked we have a list right up here
Oh to have Manchester Stockholm st.
Petersburg London Berlin nice nice
Brussels Paris I mean you remember all
of these gosh Paris is on there twice
and we'll get into this I'd like to hear
your thought in the theology here's what
I think - something that people don't
want to talk about Islam well they have
they have one weapon okay and it's guilt
and it only works because of the
appeasing left it only works because of
the appeasing progressives right now in
Western society never before right now
we have Western civilization really the
greatest civilization certainly is if
you if you want to measure it by
advancements by human rights okay so we
this is the first time when we have a
civilization Western civilization who
has an upper hand
technologically economically geo
geographically weapons name anything we
have every single advantage and we
aren't wiping out third-world tribalist
[ __ ] who should be because of guilt
and I know and sometimes we've made
those mess up but if you look at any
other civilization before it was Oh guys
guys what I just admitted this great
weapon we've got a leg we've got a leg
up let's go take over some crap that's
what happened there even look at the
Native Americans who say all was it was
it was it was just it was just slaughter
it was it was genocide no it wasn't we
came in we had guns we had guns and we
had ships I mean seriously that's what
happened at the wheel and the wheel we
go this is what happened there we said
well all right um you don't have guns
you don't have any methods of
preservation you don't use the wheel you
haven't domesticated animals something
you don't believe in personal property
you're taking one scrap you know what uh
now coexist we will not bang
that's what happened and contact is made
in right now for the first time we have
every single military economic cultural
advantage and the only weapon that Islam
has is guilt and they're winning with it
and that makes me so mad
we're showing incredible restraint and
then being kind of berated for it yeah
right so just remember the only way to
get to heaven in Islam I'm gonna be very
brief well guaranteed way the only
guaranteed way to know that you're gonna
get into heaven is to die in jihad jihad
is not as some people say inner struggle
you can't inner struggle and kill
somebody else now is this you laterally
accepted across Islam though
predominantly yes right so a lot of
times they'll go and it just depends on
if you're good at ways the bad right
there are certain pillars of Islam there
are different things you're supposed to
do as a Muslim but there's no real
accounting for God's general mood that
day in Islam which is very scary so the
only way to be guaranteed and if you
believe in a faith that says the only
way to be guaranteed in you really do
you want to go to heaven and have the
virgins
if you're lucky then then you have to do
something stupid like this and some
people you know we were talking oh the
God of the Old Testament was brutal is
like okay so is a very pronounced
judgment in military conflict in the Old
Testament you're telling me that God
wanted them to go and be completely
random after a concert people walking by
a certain point at a certain time and
not have any idea who was gonna be there
telling me that's the same God who's
gonna be happy and cheering thank you
very much for killing those innocent
kids that's the kind of God you worship
really yeah that's a good point you know
I also hope we talk with Stefan Molyneux
and he talked about his transition sort
of with Western values and understanding
sort of modern Christendom I do hope
because we have a lot of atheists who
watch we have a lot of agnostic people
who watch listen you don't have to blitz
just say you believe it's some spaghetti
monster in the sky let's say you don't
believe in it okay
but you're an atheist and economically
let's say you're libertarian or
conservative as many of you are Islam is
a political prescription so just assume
all religions are bullcrap let's go with
that you can still see one as the
greatest evil in the world and one is
not just like okay you're an atheist but
you see socialism and communism as a
tool of
evil as a tool to keep people enslaved
and you see capitalism and free
enterprise as a tool to free people
there isn't a moral equivalency you can
still be an atheist and not have to act
as all they're not all the same
no they're not in 2017 hopefully we can
find some common ground
I would love in these instances to not
know who was responsible right I don't
like that these things happen but
immediately it I don't think Christians
like we said earlier I don't think about
any they're not giving me an opportunity
to think anybody else does this yeah one
faith in the world right now and
throughout history it seems for at least
the last hundred or so years is
producing people like this one faith
yeah not multiple one faith I think I
think it's time we just put away the
bullcrap that all and Dennis Prager I
think talked about this when he's on the
show and he's spoken about about this a
lot this idea that all culturals all
cultures are somehow inherently they
share same playing field of value so
they're they're equal in value they just
come in yes some really suck some values
really really seconds and even in our
culture some values aren't equal to
other values some values take a backseat
the values of tolerance and
understanding it needs to take a
backseat to life liberty pursuit of
happiness those are those are values are
a dick trick priorities well you know
our country and we got some feedback
with mark Duplass and i'm glad that we
got almost all positive feedback because
i know mark Duplass at one point we were
talking about Planned Parenthood said
like well I feel like you want to get
into a debate here's the thing we were
the first show to host mark Duplass and
then Reuben and Glenn Beck and a bunch
of other conservatives have had him on
now we do that a lot we have these
guests on that we've never gone on
conservative shows and then other shows
do them and because other shows do not
have the access points that we have to a
lot of people in in the entertain
ministry they're afraid to question them
on anything and I try to do it as
respectfully as possible and I think I
did have a respectful conversation with
mark Duplass because here's the thing
civility is very important but it's not
the value that Trump's honesty civility
does have to be based on finding some it
has to get to the kernel of truth truth
by the way not living your truth not a
truth the truth and I do think that the
truth for me is a more important value
and I certainly think that if you use it
as a guiding light let's let's let's go
secular if you use truth as a guiding
light as opposed to compassion toss
because here's the thing a lot of people
think tolerance for compassion are
congruent with truth sometimes they're
not know sometimes you can be
compassionate and be lying to that
someone's you can be compassionate lying
to yourself yeah so like you're saying
yeah it's important some cultures suck
in the moral equivalence these let's you
know
let's tie it back in because this is a
story shot Huffington Post today okay
the the highlight it talks about gun but
people would have different opinions on
gun violence it says the gun debate
would change in an instant if Americans
witnessed the horrors that trauma
surgeons confront every day and it
explains what a bullet does to your body
this is so emblematic of the left it
biggley's I bet if you knew that bullets
really hurt people really really badly
you wouldn't ever want to use one that's
kind of the point
to quote Barack Obama and that's a
matter fact that's exactly why we
purchased them this is quite this is a
literal example of feels
ouchy bullet I bet if you felt the out
sheet of a bullet you would never want
to use them that doesn't change the
principle it doesn't change intent
doesn't change the value the reason that
I'm purchasing by the way this is this
just goes to show you how stupid editors
are at the Huffington Post that someone
said yeah I just publish that there's
something called the FBI ballistics test
they do it ballistics gelatin 10%
ballistics gelatin and it is to measure
the effectiveness of around some would
say people actually purchase their
defense of ammo based on the one that
can cause the biggest out shape the test
measures penetration expansion permanent
wound cavity hydrostatic shock the goal
is to create a round that creates the
most amount of trauma possible in a
short amount of time now why because I
want to stop the man the threat from
raping my wife or hurting my family if
it really hurts him
that doesn't change why I'm purchasing
the bullet and by the way it doesn't
delineate and this is the thing it
doesn't delineate between the good use
of firearms that's several million
incidents that every year in the country
that the firearms everybody never you I
you read this article you're like you
wonder who they're preaching at cuz
you're thinking they're like oh this is
because yeah bad guys they don't really
realize how bad they're hurting other
people yeah they don't hurt and you
realize oh no this is about lawful gun
owners protecting their families yeah
that's you there that's their target
yeah I feel like they wrote an article
that said the sky is blue bullets do
damage yeah realists do damage and if
you knew if they really hurt you
wouldn't buy them because you wouldn't
want to hurt the people who are trying
to hurt is it anybody in America who
doesn't know that bullets hurt does
anybody think it feels good the whole
HuffPo all the white chicks at HuffPo
it's a lot we sit on in 2015 they're the
same thing is one a gun
take a bullet
and it was like the site and the idea of
the piece was if you take a bullet you
can survive then you have the right to
use it against your assailant um at what
point do we just you know what we don't
need to understand and validate
everything you know what I don't need to
walk a mile in a rapist shoes I don't
need to take a bullet to be able to
shoot a multiple a serial killer with a
bullet I don't it's okay because morally
I'm okay with firing a hollow-point into
the chest cavity of a rapist I can just
think that you know you're just supposed
to be at what point are you supposed to
be understanding everything it's a while
you're being raped did your daddy just
your daddy never hug you enough no I had
pretty good parents I just like having
sex with dudes I mean it some people
don't way you're purchasing hollow
points I want to buy these could kill
people Oh Mike let's get rid of those
just give me the condoms because I'll be
raped hard very Vaseline yes please and
this it doesn't the point I'm drawing us
back around to Islamic terrorism and
this is the fundamental different
worldview of the left like you said
about cultures it doesn't change the
walking a mile and shoes and validating
and understanding that's nice to a point
but it doesn't change the purpose of
your actions the purpose of me or you
purchasing a firearm and the most
effective round possible that I can
handle with a firearm is to protect
loved ones is to protect the innocent is
to fight evil the purpose of terrorists
who blow up people at an ariana grande
concert specifically targeting innocent
civilians is not changed because they
find out there's an out G the purpose is
the same and it's evil it doesn't matter
how many times you sit the terrorists
down on the couch to listen to him I
don't know and when he was ablaze he
called me a terrorist and I guess until
now I just didn't realize how much that
bothers me well did you ever maybe think
the reason he resorted to name-calling
was because he was on fire and maybe he
was also in pain
wait you mean that burning Christians
alive in cages because this physical
thing
[Music]
icky
[Music]
but how do I reach this terrorists
alright we'll be back with Gavin
McGinnis I hope he hope you can make us
laugh many of you are still unaware of
the items available at louder with
Crowder shop comm not only do they make
you look and feel better but they serve
a multitude of purposes like our
socialism is for [ __ ] shirts
assisting in identifying potential
allies I think it's pretty funny or our
bad hombres firearm t-shirt helping you
know who to avoid I might have take that
shirt to mean you support some kind of
firearm registry or this one hey look
it's my face I hate it though louder
with Crowder shop calm isn't for
everyone
but can i buy them up from the shop
without joining the mug club no the rest
of you check out the merchandise at
ladder with Crider shop comm today
[Music]
all right let's look at there's no way
that respect intros there's no respect
he just noticed about compound Mediacom
whatever who Kevin McGinnis thank you
notice there goes look at my shoulders I
have this exact same body as Grover well
they brought it in the first autistic
Muppet to Sesame Street I always thought
that was Super Grover he had the helmet
he was running into things it was a
horrible message was no way to
tactically do that oh no every kid would
put on a cape in a bike helmet just run
into a wall and then get hurt and get
put in suspension Gavin would get his
compound Mediacom thank you for being
with us sir and having me I wish you
were under you know what let's hear your
Grover I don't remember what what did I
just do Eastern European accent that's
that is good that is good it's a good
Grover but now you ask well I think
what's Frank Oz he did all those pretty
my think they were both from Chechnya
yes yes and and Elmo just raped people
behind the scenes who knew we should
have seen it coming well I wish you were
under better circumstances obviously of
your show so I'm assuming you covered it
earlier today we just did in the first
segment Gavin McInnes if Gavin McGinnis
is president today what do we do about
Islamic terrorism let's just start with
that okay first thing we have to do is
stop putting our brain into other
people's brains and saying they want an
open discussion they want tolerance they
want diversity they want to show up for
the qat of our talks no and I talked to
Talib Starks about this he worked at a
home for wayward youth and he said some
kids should be cut loose there
irreparable
you don't see that in the Disney film
like they don't so she'll be getting his
radio just beating the hell out of kids
you just need some love you're a bad kid
I think with Isis and with the sjw's and
with radical Islam we have to go
we're not compatible yeah I'm dumb I'm
trying to work this out building a wall
getting you out of here making your life
hell if you want to try to attack me we
need to make it clear to Islam that
we're not friends now there's moderate
Muslims that we can live with but they
are anti Islamic in the sense that you
keep getting drink they're not true to
the Quran if they're friends with us
basically yes and I'm not gonna lie I
often am mistrustful of Muslims who
drink and go to strip clubs because I
assume they're taking themselves out in
the jihad only a few days later that's
the only way to absolve themselves of it
Muslims are not feed the red kidney
beans of the chili there're more of the
the habanero pepper yeah also take over
everything and that's only they mutate
well the more the botulism yeah of the
kidney beans gas-station got what I
don't want you to cook for me every no
no I oh by the way one of my writers
Cory said roo-roo I don't know so oh
there you go
yeah the proud boy thing okay I don't
know so that's what we have to do first
is recognize that we're not the same and
radical Islam is not compatible with the
West
I don't think Islam is compatible with
the West no that's the next thing we
have to do is stop bullshitting and be
honest with ourselves about what is
going on like the baddack land pictures
we didn't see those four months later we
didn't find out about that they were
eviscerating pregnant woman and they
were removing men's genitalia and
sticking them in their mouths we didn't
learn about that for a year after
because the authorities censored it I
want to see these photos well I don't
want to see them per se but right now
the world to see a maimed 13 year old
girl yeah with nails in her hand well
and I always wonder if only you know the
Assange's and the people who you know
some people they love to praise now if
only they went after that was the same
amount of vigor as they went after you
know people laughing at naked terrorists
at Abu Ghraib but like well how about
them shoving a man's own genitals in his
mouth no no no the Germans
barking at a naked pile of terrorists
who just burned people alive that's the
real torture that's the corruption and
I'm fine with it
I'm fine with it but I've been to
Guantanamo Bay I've seen the prisons
I've watched them play their stupid
little X boxes and I just wish there
were a fraction of the outrage and
that's where I part ways with sort of
the the I guess sort of Julian Assange
breed of the art alt right well justjust
be even-handed with it because one is
problematic to use your term one is
there's some corruption and one is
absolute pure evil from the pit of hell
but if you say that then they become
sjw's and they're offended I talked to
this guy today count dank EULA and he's
looking at a year in prison because he
taught his girlfriend's plug to Zeke
I'll also in Britain we have these guys
who spent is a poor use of time because
anyone who's ever trained a pug to do
anything knows it takes an ordinate
amount of time to get them to do
anything he did a good job
we all saw these two guys in Britain who
spent two years each for putting bacon
on a mosque yeah one of them died in
prison we also have Tommy Robinson sent
to prison for being too anti Islam he
was almost killed in prison yet they
have grooming gangs raping girls they
have yeah it's a ma the mosque that
radicalized this suicide bomber who blew
himself up in Manchester at the concert
surrounding that mosque there was 16
different terrorists who had died abroad
fighting for Isis yeah so Britain is
zeroed in on these so-called racist
Nazis whatever ruining their lives
meanwhile they totally tolerate Islam
yeah and it's because I think it's
because their brains can't handle the
truth it's if there was 22 dogs killed
at an ariana grande concert there would
be a lot more outrage yeah it would be
going on it can digest animal abuse they
they just can't fit human abuse in their
heads no well that's what I was talking
about you know if for example if you
were to bring in a Christian immigrant
they were to say by the way yeah I'm
coming in from was it was it was it the
young turks tried to blame the radical
Irish it was they tried to blame you
blame IRA did they actually do that
though
I don't know I've heard that I cannot
confirm it but someone tried to as
someone was actually asking me was it
Isis was at IRA I'm Aloha where are you
hearing this at the Young Turks why I
can't substantiate it but the fact that
he was it was even circulating to me is
absolutely unreal
you know here's something by the way
Jared you know this not gay dude have
you ever tried to call the mosque uh
Guinness yeah McGinnis you were tried to
call much oh yeah I've ever tried to
call her mosque they never answer no and
there's no answering machine seriously
try and find your local mosques
off-hours try to solve no one answers
the phone we did it I won't say because
I don't want to reveal yet but we were
working on a video and we had a list of
mosques I don't know a dozen an Islamic
Center Islamic sensing no answer no
voicemail a one would almost think it's
like a front when the cops in Paris
invaded all those mosques after bad a
clan they found 100% of them with
radical paraphernalia pamphlets
propaganda no they weren't necessarily a
radical mosque no but if you wanted to
go radical there's your pamphlets
there's your particular part of the room
the yeah free influence room it's like a
box of free condoms at a public high
school is here you go how to burden them
alive engage every church has the Joel
Osteen rack yes proud of it for you yeah
I know well you know we were talking
like this where everyone you know
Facebook they're talking about anti
Islam blaspheming on Facebook here's
something people don't think about every
single Muslim alive blast is blaspheming
against the Christian faith we don't
want him dead every single one is
following a man who said Christ is not
the guy he says he was the Jews
subverted the text everything you
believed in that Bible is [ __ ] until
I correct it and if you don't follow me
we have the right to kill you every
single Quran believing Muslim is
blaspheming against Christ so let's just
do it two big spaghetti monster in the
sky but just as far as we're using the
terminology none of us want them dead
for following a different religion why
is that never even considered I am kind
of you know it's hard to write comedy in
days like this yeah I'm sure you
probably same thing woke up this morning
you're like I gotta get this out that I
can get to processing it in humor
I'm too mad to joke around these days
like Stephen Fry is is lambasted by the
Irish for blaspheming when Islam sets up
little tables I mean every time I go to
Brett I go every summer and there's
these tables in every suburb this
surrounds London where they sit there
and they advocate for Sharia law where
women are human garbage yeah and if a
white male was to say the exact same
things that Sharia says in fact I'm
gonna do that there's a march against
Sharia coming up in New York and I'm
just gonna come up with a cigar and go
guys guys guys simmer down this thing is
the best you know yeah you get to horny
walking down the street you put a bag on
them these guys want to put a bag on
chicks so you don't get to horny and I
know they're always happening yeah but
no this was rape that was rape this was
right in Sharia law they don't they
don't take any of your testimony
seriously it's not to have the value
what else you know how this morning your
wife never wants to sleep with you
what does Sharia stuff you get to beat
the crap out of her until she blows you
it's the best thing in the world what
are we doing here yeah you should create
that that character should be called
Sharia Cagney you dirty infidel you put
a rape your wife you dirty infidel oh
I'm glad you're able to make me laugh
somewhat well you know a lot of people
upset okay listen you know I'm not the
biggest the biggest Trump fan I don't
hate the guy want everything I ever say
about Donald Trump is from a spirit I
think you understand this I want this
country to do well and I want the
administration to serve the country well
I think they've made some mistakes where
they've given left gifts I don't think
calling terrorists evil losers is one oh
no I think he could have gone further I
would have liked it paired with you know
with the most evil religion there is in
the world today you know more so going
after the actual ideological extremism
but I think I don't understand this I
think maybe Donald Trump understand it
on some level these people don't fear
death the punishment must be more shame
they need to be shamed they need to be
shamed physically before they die there
needs to be a message out there right
now like Vlad with the flag the Impaler
lie below realize that Muslims didn't
take over his castle that's the basis of
Dracula you know why because all of the
guys
tried to come and conquer his home
before you were on spikes like human
cornfield he said alright this is what
we're gonna do to your friends now we
can't be cruel we have to be humane but
guess what isn't it wonderful that we
have tools to are available to us that
are not maiming that are not permanently
damaging but shame these people which is
the message that they understand and we
can't do it say they don't admire
capitulation they don't admire
benevolence they see it as weakness they
only admire strength that you see this
in Israel very clearly the wall has been
the best thing that ever happened to
them and every time these Israelis
kvetch and and stroked their beards and
go well you misunderstand and the the
Muslims have a totally different genetic
trajectory their past thousand years has
been about strength and toughness and
ruthlessness so when you sit there and
you say hey Gaza we're gonna take down
20 homes and bulldoze them they go ha ha
you you you blinked you know right I win
and we're guilty the same thing here in
the West like this Southern Poverty Law
Center crap where they go the face of
terrorism in America is white well that
would be a postcard that I wouldn't buy
but yes you go the cases they use for
this is like some white supremacists
killed his roommate and the guy who flew
a plane into the IRS that's right wing
terrorism and and they have things like
some guy who was a Muslim but then
converted no he's a Nazi converted
Muslim they killed his not suffering any
way they throw everything in the mix for
that to get their numbers up on white
terrorism yeah and then for Muslim
terrorism they start counting things as
incidents so September 11th was one
incident San Bernardino was one incident
pulse nightclub was one incident that's
now three things and the PAC match that
up with some rude phone call and some
dumb skinhead fight and you go you are
real feline so we did for a long that's
American history acts that didn't happen
that's in black and white no it's not
security footage it's just that it was a
creative choice oh my god half the time
they show these pictures do when they
come with these surveys and it's some
Italian
Nazi skinheads from 1981 that they just
sort of juxtaposed with their fake data
but that's what I meant at the beginning
when the first step to all of this is to
just be honest and have free speech
which Britain doesn't have and that's
why I always say the amendments are in
the right order
yeah of importance because the First
Amendment tells you that you know in in
three months they did there was 40,000
PDFs of that jihadist magazine in spire
downloaded in Britain yeah and we could
only really get a few that were legally
that we could see were downloaded there
most of them were downloaded on proxies
yeah and then were mad at a guy who
trains his pug to Z guile I still hope
they I still think it's in poor taste
but I would go back to the WikiLeaks
these people why aren't they going after
people who download it if they're going
to I think it's an invasion of privacy I
don't want them snooping through my
iPhone but why are they going after
people who are downloading radical
Islamic terrorism pamphlets I think it's
great to entertain it's fun the seth
rich conspiracy theories but there do
need to be some priorities here and I
get the Donald Trump and the Pepe and
the trolling and all that's fun and
great but we need to get to the next
rung in the ladder and right now that
happens to be a rung that requires
people standing up and facing the
greatest evil that our time has ever
seen and I mean that by the way that's
not hyperbole everything the Nazis
believed is Lama
terrorists believed as well and they
beat the crap out of the women yeah
that's a great point
hey I'm about to run out of batteries
can I get my can I get my charger my
phone thing I mean my computer thing
without screwing up your show where we
at 15 or 15 well we're gonna have to let
you go anyways I guess Gavin ah let's
have you back soon
I got 2% so let's keep going I was I
didn't know how long this okay no um I
just is I'm glad that I'm kind of moving
through some of this with you here I
think that just a port hey okay let's
talk about this Roger Moore died know
that I don't like that segue to get back
to Tommy Robinson in Britain he said
today he goes where the Lions England
everywhere you go in England there's a
bloody lion out front we used to have
that raw we used to be lions and now
we're king please I thought he was gonna
go with the lines and then laugh
analogy he kind of just abandoned the
analogy and when it's going inside
Pussycats he said to [ __ ]
but um here's a crazy theory is it
possible that uh genetically we took all
the brave Brits and created America and
the ones that are left are not
adventurous genetically I think we I
think we stole their shows I do think we
did I think we did a shank soon and took
their soul out of their body with the
American Revolution if you think listen
a lot of people to move past it because
obviously gonna be controversial but you
make some very good points the
amendments are in the right order and
this is why I will say you know I would
never go to a Sharia March in New York
now the reason for that is I think
people know I've I've had some very very
serious run-ins with Islam beyond kind
of fun internet stuff and that's because
in New York doesn't respect the Second
Amendment see that it would be self
regulating if you could go do a Sharia
March and guess what you can also
exercise your Second Amendment right but
in New York you can't and so you're
sitting ducks trying to practice your
First Amendment so you're right the
order is very important right well I'll
be paying people who are able to
circumvent the insane gun laws in New
York and be armed but yeah it's funny
that to exercise your First Amendment
you need to be surrounded with the
Second Amendment in this country and
it's amazing that the the founding
fathers thought of that or sorry as
blacklivesmatter calls him that our
founding for parents because fathers is
sexist talked about it's okay to kill
white people he calls them for parents
who who said this it was a professor a
black guy forget what college but uh he
did a podcast where he talked about when
it's okay to kill white people and it's
a nine minute answer he gives that gets
back into Django Unchained and now from
of that movie it was two fictional I I
think it's an easy question answer when
is it okay to kill white people when
they become radicalized terrorists there
we go there's a good litmus test um
Gavin McGinnis compound Mediacom where
people can go watch your show listen
honestly men stay safe they're for doing
that Sharia March in New York I'd be
careful thanks for scaring the crap out
of me we what we want you that we want
you to stick around we want you on the
show people always the most requested
guests I think we get our
then shapiro Gavin McGinnis and then a
lot of people really wanted mark Duplass
back they really liked him so much I
think is I think his thing died I think
it's thing died it dies that means it's
time to go you hear something that was
Gavin McGinnis you can follow him on
twitter is compound Mediacom we'll be
right back wrapping this up I think
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I've been expecting you
jihadi Bond I was wondering what took
you so long to find me let's just say I
was caught up with a dinner date well I
hope she knows how to handle that left
hook of yours she did unfortunately for
her it was the right upper ring you've
always had a way of the lady he's double
six six well that's simply because I
always understood something you could
not then what's that what you call charm
I call raping and repeatedly and beating
them without mercy well to put that my
notebook of pickup tips
Mr Bond enough small talk who are you
working for who is behind this mug club
you cannot stop it besides it's not who
it's what those reels are any motion of
force which cannot be stopped
we'll see what YouTube has to say about
this my club is a force beyond YouTube
it cannot be contained cannot be stopped
do you really think that you do with all
its power with all its featured content
with all its Young Turks they cannot
take care of your merry band of friends
what happens when your precious mug Club
is banned or worse they monetize my club
operates outside of YouTube outside
YouTube but that's Internet suicide
you're right Mr Bond YouTube merely
provides shall we say the platform to
realm our club as YouTube continues this
jihad on free speech effectively using
its own power against itself as users
continue to join my club YouTube is no
longer needed to reach ones user base it
is suicide jihadi bond with YouTube's
finger on the trigger I've heard enough
who is behind this supposedly
unstoppable mug Club you still don't get
it it is not who it's
I
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right Gavin McGinnis always glad to
have two Gavin McInnes on all these good
you just kind of disappear I ditched you
never know he talked about the the anti
Sharia parade and then he's gone
tomorrow we have Oh Benjamin tomorrow we
have Jordan Peterson on for an extended
chat so send in your top questions for
Jordan Peterson and then Thursday Tommy
Lauren Thursday we have time you learn
right there in that chair live in-studio
her first kind of longer interview I
would say in person since the
controversy and she just took a new job
with a trio Trump I guess you'd say PAC
or political group so be asking her
about that and just tomorrow you know I
think it's a good time that Jordan
Peterson obviously is a genius he's a
professor he talks a lot about truths he
talks a lot about philosophy about
theology about new gender theory about
different you know equivalencies between
religion and virtues and values so I I'm
looking forward to sitting and talking
with him like I said sometimes were
working through the same issues as you
are here on this show and not get jaded
at a good point during the break we was
talking about we talked about earlier in
the show how some cultures suck and you
know truth justice sometimes honesty
these are values that I tend to put any
hierarchy higher than compassion and
understanding if they don't intersect
yeah but you were saying I don't think
that's you are mutually exclusive and I
think I think the best thing that can
happen in many situations is when you
when you merge the two and you marry the
two together you think of you know you
have an alcoholic father who's just
beating his kids every other night the
most compassionate thing the most
understanding and fruitful thing you
could do is administer truth in justice
you know perhaps in that man's life
that's the best outcome that you know
you can you can marry a tune that they
don't that they don't have to be
exclusive no they don't they're not
mutually exclusive and but they also
aren't necessarily congruent know
and that's important for people to note
sometimes compassion
sometimes understanding is not congruent
with truth or justice sometimes you can
say you know what yeah I uh I understand
why you hacked that woman to death
because you thought the radio was
talking to you if I thought the radio
was telling me to do it too I maybe
would have but that doesn't change
justice here that doesn't change the
truth of course I'm taking an extreme
example to make a point it's good point
they're not meet you and I think we do I
try to do a good job of that on this
show no I try to be compassionate I
always say listen I don't care as much
as about civility as I do about honesty
but this is one of the few shows where
we will have people on and host their
opinions and let them speak and have
fruitful discussions and that does step
listen I've been honest about it we're
talking about religion today that stems
from my Christian worldview that is a
very Christian worldview that you can
forgive that you can pray for your
enemies and you can still administer
justice and that's the laid out with a
very specific set of laws biblically in
the Christian faith that's also by the
way very unique we talked about this
idea that that compassion then mercy I
don't need a got these actually weren't
universal values and unfortunately it's
been perverted where where leftists are
using these values which which are
virtuous they're using them and turning
them into guilt to appease evil and
that's not what Christianity is about
but again you can still be truthful you
can still be just and and be
compassionate and I think a lot of
people sometimes think it's one or the
other no it's not especially yeah you
know from a biblical perspective a
Christian perspective the the most kind
and loving thing we can do to somebody
is to tell them truth and to present
them with truth yeah and that's
something I think that I think even as
we see atheists and agnostics our
friends can possibly get on board with I
think I can understand that better than
when people you know on the far left it
well this is why the left is losing
because they say if you if you knew what
a bullet was like you wouldn't use a gun
that's their logic you know if we
understand it well you know okay let's
use that let's talk about we talk about
this it kind of goes back to the idea of
the victim culture creating unintended
actual victims right we've tried to be
understanding we've tried to be
multicultural and let Islam have its own
identity in Western society we've done
that now we've tried the left's way for
a good portion of time and we showed you
a list of year more and more innocent
people have died so when trying to be
understanding
because understanding because hashtag
non-muslims because we don't want to
offend people other people die
the fake victims the Twitter victims the
people who are perpetually offended the
social justice warrior Muslims the Shan
Kings we have to appease them the Farah
Khan's it gotta be we don't want to we
don't want them to feel excluded so
you've been doing that and the macro
result people over you're dying feel
being blown up in an area out of grande
concert so you can fool yourself
sometimes I think that just compassion
alone or just civility just
understanding alone just validation
alone is somehow being a good person
sometimes your gym just actually
abetting evil and you need to find where
where justice and truth civility honesty
compassion intersect and you need to
know which values are are held higher
college we talk about Gavin the
Constitution with the First Amendment
Second Amendment we have these in that
order a specific order I think truth
specifically needs to be higher than
compassion for the sake of compassion
we'll talk more about that with Jordan
Peterson tomorrow for a full hour so
tune in again this is free ladder with
how to react free crowd or hashtag free
Crowder hashtag that's how you know it's
good
[Music]